[Musique]
LCP Assemblée Nationale en partenariat
avec mgenen première mutuelle des agents
du service public présente état de
[Musique]
santé
depuis quelques années les sportifs de
haut niveau commencent à lancer l'alerte
leur santé mentale est mise à rue
d'épreuve on a la croyance commune que
le sportif de haut niveau en fait et ben
on est des machines des machines à
résultat des des machines physiques des
machines mentales la recherche de la
performance sportive pousse les athlètes
à se dépasser et certains finissent par
développer des comportements à risque
comme des
addictions j'ai été beaucoup en
surentraînement à à m'épuiser finalement
m'épuiser tant physiquement que
mentalement la parole se libère autour
des difficultés psychologiques mais le
soutien proposé aux sportifs n'est pas
encore à la hauteur voilà je dirait un
psychologue par équipe ça serait le ça
serait une bonne une bonne base de
sécurité psychologique pour
tous alors comment améliorer
l'accompagnement des
sportif santé mentale quand les athlètes
vont mal c'est le thème de ce numéro
d'état de
[Musique]
santé bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans
état de santé c'est un sacré paradoxe ce
sont des immenses champions des très
très grands sportifs forcément ils sont
très très très en forme et pourtant ils
peuvent tomber en dépression il y a un
exemple qui est très connu en France
c'est Camille Lacour par exemple le
nageur bonjour à vous Guillaume tecoulet
merci beaucoup d'être avec nous vous
êtes un de ces grands champions vous
êtes champion de tir à l'arc ce que je
propose c'est qu'on regarde tout de
suite votre
[Musique]
parcours guillaume toucoulet est numéro
1 et recordman mondial de tir à l'arc
and dis sport ayant perdu l'usage de son
bras gauche suite à un accident de moto
tire avec la bouche à l'aide d'une
languette en cuir fixée sur la corde
guillaume toucoulet est un passionné de
sport depuis toujours il pratiquait déjà
l'aviron à haut niveau avant son
accident puis il revient à la
compétition à peine un an après en
équipe de France en disport en
2013 en 2017 il découvre le tir à l'arc
par hasard un sport qui devient
rapidement une passion en 6 ans à peine
il est numéro 1 mondial et enchaîne les
titres et les
médailles
sensibilisé aux problématiques de santé
mentale tout au long de sa carrière il
intervient régulièrement dans les
[Musique]
écoles donc on a compris Guillaume
toucolet vous êtes un grand champion
merci d'être avec nous hein parce que
vous préparez les Jeux paralympiques
donc c'est un paradoxe effectivement le
sport ça maintient en forme mais ça
blesse aussi physiquement des grands
sportifs blessés et puis ça peut
atteindre la santé mentale vous vous
avez euh était parfois déstabilisé au
point de bon de d'être empêché dans
votre activité ou pas oui bien sûr euh
dans la vie d'un sportif de niveau même
dans le sport en club on est souvent
impacté par par ça bien sûr souvent
impacté par ça c'est quelque chose dont
vous parlez avec vos collègues non pas
trop parce que c'est c'est un peu une
une marque de faiblesse on va dire la
santé mentale des sportif c'est vrai que
alors pour le coup vous êtes là pour en
témoigner on en parle de de plus en plus
plus il y a des exemples effectivement
qui ont mis le sujet sur la table
[Musique]
regardez en 2021 deux athlètes superstar
ont conduit à lever le tabou de la santé
mentale dans le sport de haut niveau la
plus emblématique c'est la gymnaste
Simon BES quatre fois médaillé d'or à
Rio elle arrive grande favorite au giio
de Tokyo mais en pleine finale du
concours général par équipe elle quitte
soudainement la compétition pour prendre
soin de sa santé et met sa carrière
entre parenthèses pendant 2 ans de
semaines plus tôt à Roland Garos la
championne de tennis Naomi Osaka déclare
forfait en refusant de se présenter aux
conférences de presse dans la foulée
elle révèle souffrir de dépression
depuis
2018 depuis de nombreux autres athlètes
ont suivi en mettant ouvertement des
mots sur la dépression dont il souffre
le nageur Michael felps et en France
l'escrimeuse isaora tibus le footballeur
Paul Pogba ou encore le nageur Camille
Laour d'ailleurs une enquête menée par
l'association comité éthique et sport
révèle que sur 1200 sportifs 80 % ont
déjà ressenti de la tristesse ou un
manque de confiance ainsi parlerit de
ses difficultés dans le sport et de
moins en moins vu comme une faiblesse
l'exemple de Simon BES et Naomi Osaka
montre que cela peut même être une force
toutes deux ont repris le chemin de la
compétition avec quatre nouvelles
médaille d'or et une d'argent pour Simon
BES au dernier mondiaux de
[Musique]
gymnastique Guillaume toucoulet quand on
est un sportif de haut niveau c'est très
très dur parce que il a fallu se battre
comme des chiens c'est hyper compétitif
par définition ça ça ça peut faire mal
quand même dans la tête non ça peut
faire mal ça peut ranger ouais
effectivement après tout dépend comment
on pratique le sport et quelles sont nos
propres motivations et quand vous êtes
dans un club ça c'est quelque chose qui
est un peu désamorcé par les coachs ils
vous en parlent ils essayent de de faire
en sorte que ça ne se produise pas ou
c'est finalement non c'est chacun se
débrouille comme il peut avec ça non
c'est chacun se débrouille un peu comme
comme il peut avec ses avec ses armes et
puis il y a toujours des petites
préférences dans dans des clubs même
même à petit niveau donc je pense qu'on
est aussi habitué à ça mais c'est petit
à petit au fur et à mesure ben ça ça ça
ça peut ranger alors c'est le mental
d'un sportif c'est quand même
particulier parce que vous vous m'avez
dit vous étiez rongé par le doute avant
pendant l'entraînement et cetera puis
moment de la compétition c'est ça c'est
c'est-à-dire ben je suis quelqu'un qui
doute beaucoup et en fait le doute me me
permet de progresser en entraînement
c'estàdire que je remets pas mal de
choses en question mais est-ce que je
suis sûr de que ce que je fais c'est
bien ou est-ce que je suis sûr que je
suis sur la bonne voie voilà donc ça
c'est quelque chose ouis c'est pas un
doute paralysant c'est pas un doute
paralysant c'est un doute qui me permet
de progresser voilà par contre quand je
suis en compétition ben je doute plus il
y a plus de place au doute quand on est
en compète ah oui on y pense plus moi
non personnellement moi non alors tout
le monde n'a pas cette force que vous
avez Guillaume toucoulet alexia lpon est
allé à l'INSEP pour voir comment le
sujet de la santé mentale est pris au
sérieux est pris en chat et on va
entendre des témoignages vous allez voir
passionnant à tout de
[Musique]
suite
inep à Paris le lieu d'entraînement de
nombreux futurs grands champions
olympiques dans l'un des couloirs
les visages de la gloire sportive
nationale champion multimédaillé visage
triomphant mais aussi une souffrance qui
elle ne s'affiche pas
est l'une des rares personnes à savoir
la décrypter car psychologue Aline son
travail consiste à s'assurer du bon
équilibre psychique de ces sportifs de
haut niveau on peut intervenir en amont
en
prévention pour éviter en
fait d'arriver sur des problématiques
lourdes qui auraient pu être géré
différemment évité adapté en fonction en
fait de du parcours de chacun voilà je
dirais un psychologue par équipe ça
serait le ça serait une bonne une bonne
base de sécurité psychologique pour
tous exemple ici dans le pôle judo de
l'établissement Madeleine Malonga est
une judocate qui a enchaîné les
médailles double championne d'Europe
championne du monde médaillé d'argent
aux Jeux Olympiques à première vue une
réussite sportive sans nuage mais
moralement la réalité est bien
différente on a tendance à se dire que
ou du moins à croire que on a des
périodes difficiles que lorsqu'on a des
des échecs mais pas du tout parfois on
peut même avoir des victoires et pas
être être vraiment prêt à à le gérer moi
je sais que ma période post-olympique
après la victoire de de ces deux
médailles et ben ça a été aussi
difficile à à gérer ce qui a été
difficile à gérer bah c'est déjà
retrouver un petit peu le sens à ma
pratique parce que forcément je suis
partie chez mes parents à l'âge de 14
ans pour bah pour être championne du
monde olympique et bah du coup quand on
atteint cela après c'est commême un peu
être au sommet d'une montagne et et se
rendre compte qu'en fait c'est juste
quelque chose de super mais rien ne
change après ça en fait une remise en
cause d'autant plus difficile à
surmonter qu'elle est difficilement
avoable le sport de haut niveau a pour
réputation de ne pas s'attarder sur les
états d'âmes de ces champions pour ces
derniers se sentir moralement mal est
considéré comme une faiblesse nous dans
le judo c'est pas quelque chose dont on
parle énormément parce que bah nous on a
la particul éérité un peu de faire un
sport de combat donc il y a je trouve
qu'il y a ce cette croyance un peu de si
on montre notre vulnérabilité on sait
comme si on montrait notre faiblesse et
en fait moi dans cette période là j'ai
appris vraiment que ma vulnérabilité et
ben en fait c'était vraiment une force
et pas du tout une
faiblesse pression morale en cas de
victoire mais en cas de défaite c'est
encore pire la semaine dernière
Madeleine a perdu les championnats
d'Europe une déception immense pour pour
elle mais qu'elle relativise grâce à
ellise la
psychologue comment tu vas madame bah
écoute ça va franchement ça va malgré la
déception et bah cette compétition ratée
franchement ça va moi c'est frustrant
parce que je me dis punaise j'ai
tellement
travaillé j'ai mis toutes les choses en
place pour que ça marche et ça marche
pas donc c'est là où il y a la
frustration mais je suis convaincue que
ça va marcher à un moment donné on
attend beaucoup du sportif et le sportif
en fait fait Semet au service des autres
le sportif de haut niveau aime maîtriser
les choses avoir du contrôle sur ce
qu'il fait et toute vulnérabilité en
fait peut être vécu comme quelque chose
qui peut le
fragiliser par rapport à ses adversaires
par rapport à ses coéquipiers par
rapport à ses sélectionneurs voilà on a
la croyance commune que le sportif de
haut niveau en fait et ben on est des
machines des machines à résultat des des
machines physiques des des machines
mental et et ça en fait on le cultive en
plus depuis notre plus jeune âge on a
même cette sensation je pense que on
sera quelqu'un on aura de l'estime de
nous-même et notre confiance en
nous-même que lorsqu'on aura des
médailles et malheureusement bah c'est
très dur d'avoir des médailles et quand
on n' pas de médaille et ben on se
retrouve un petit peu nu
seul nul aussi surtout et et incompris
en fait on sait plus réellement comment
s'iden suff on continue ça marche ça
marche allez bonne journée à tooup
exactement bonne journée à toi madame ça
marche toi aussi mon courage merci
beaucoup dans l'accompagnement
psychologique des sportifs linp fait
figure de bon
élève ciao
ciao certaines fédérations commencent à
suivre son exemple mais la santé mentale
des sportifs est encore trop souvent
reléguée au second plan
[Musique]
Guillaume toucoulet c'est intéressant le
témoignage de cette championne de judo
voilà ça lui est arrivé elle en a parlé
c'est déjà énorme oui puisque ce qui est
intéressant dans ce qu'elle dit c'est
que même quand on gagne on peut être
atteint de dépression en fait parce que
si c'est son objectif d'être champion
olympique ou champion du monde une fois
qu'on l'a atteint ben on se dit mais
qu'est-ce que je vais faire maintenant
ça quand on a atteint le sommet voilà on
dit mais qu'est-ce qu'on qu'est-ce qu'on
fait maintenant c'est voilà on est
complètement désemparé c'est ça ça peut
arriver chez certains sportifs ouais et
donc l'idée c'est que c'est la descente
qui est difficile quoi redescendre sur
terre avec un objectif qui n'existe plus
quand on est arrivé à si ce n'est de le
réitérer si ce n'est de le recommencer
c'est ça il faudrait pouvoir se préparer
à ça et c'est toujours la même chose
est-ce qu'il y a des Sass est-ce qu'on
est accompagné pour ça quand on est
voilà dans un club de sport même
professionnel au niveau des jeux
alors nous en handisport on n'est pas
dans des grosses structures comme comme
unincep on évolue chacun de notre côté
puis on se retrouve sur des
rassemblements donc on l'évoque pas
forcément même si nos entraîneurs ils
sont sensibles à ça moi je je peux
comprendre que certaines personnes
partent en dépression par le manque de
résultat euh parce que c'est le milieu
du du sport notamment au niveau c'est
c'est assez dur dès qu'on fait des
contreperformances on voit aussi que
l'entourage on est un peu moins bien
suivi on est donc on se dit mais je suis
nul en fait qu'est-ce qui se passe et
donc là on peut vraiment rentrer dans
cet enonnage là et et avoir du mal à
s'en sortir alors vous vous êtes assez
remarquable parce que vous êtes champion
tir à l'arc avant vous étiez dans
l'aviron ouais et à un moment vous
n'avez pas été sélectionné justement
pour les jeux et là vous avez eu un coup
quand même ah oui ça étit très dur je
l'ai pas compris vous tropvz juste hein
de pas être sélectionné et comment vous
vous avez fait alors face à ce revers je
n'ai pas pu reprendre la viriron à cause
de ça justement c'est quelque chose qui
m'a m'a profondément blessé parce que ce
ça faisait pas partie de mes valeurs
sportives donc j'ai complètement arêé ah
oui ça vous a dégoûté ça m'a ouais ça
m'a ça m'a dégoûté et donc ben j'ai
continué je quand même continu le sport
j'ai découvert un autre sport et donc on
m'a proposé de tirer à l'arc avec la
bouche et en fait je suis très content
parce que c'est un sport que j'ai appris
à aimer alors mention personnelle avant
ce cette grosse déception pour les j
vous avez donc eu un accident de moto
qui vous a privé de l'usage une partie
de votre bras et ce qui est remarquable
c'est que vous êtes tout de suite
remonter sur le cheval tout de suite
c'est par le sport que vous vous êtes
dit je vais m'en sortir c'est ça en fait
j'ai j'ai quasiment jamais jamais
déprimé euh il m'est arrivé ça je l'ai
très très vite compris et en fait pour
aller de l'avant il fallait mettre ça de
côté et puis et puis avancer quoi ça
s'appelle un mental d'acier de façon un
peu commune vous avez dit voilà vous
avez retrouvé en tout cas une passion
pour le sport grâce au tir à l'arc je
sais pas si ça s'appelle l'adrénaline
mais c'est vrai que le sport quand on
réussit ça procure des satisfactions
très fortes et parfois on tombe dedans
entre guillemets comme on tombe dans la
Cooke ou ou dans une drogue et ben on
tombe dans le sport et on va parler de
ça parce que c'est très très important
l'addiction au sport qui touche bon les
sportifs de haut niveau ça peut arriver
mais beaucoup de sportifs amateurs c'est
le reportage d'Alexia
[Musique]
leparon depuis son enfance Nathalie
pratique la course à pied à haut niveau
au fil des kilomètres cette pratique
sportive est devenue une addiction pour
elle
en fin de semaine si j'étais arrivé à 95
km non ben je ressortais le soir pour
aller dépasser les S bornes en fait et
quand j'avais éteint les S bornes en
fait c'était comme un soulagement
franchement là je me dis mais comment on
peut arriver dans des états comme ça
c'est là où je me dis ouais c'est une
maladie exemple actuellement une grave
blessure l'empêche de pratiquer son
sport favori
elle s'est donc rabattu sur le vélo
aujourd'hui pourtant malgré leseff
sportif elle a le sentiment que quelque
chose s'est brisé dans sa
vie non c'est un un réel besoin et il y
a un manque et c'est très très dur à à
accepter en fait avec l'expérience
Nathalie a appris à prendre du recul
désormais elle accepte plus facilement
les mises au repos de son corps car elle
a pris conscience que trop de sport est
mauvais pour sa santé j'ai été beaucoup
en
surentraînement à à m'épuiser finalement
mé puuisé tant physiquement que
mentalement donc j'ai quand même fait ce
qui est très très rare déjà j'ai fait
six fracture de fatigue de ruptures du
tendon de l'insertion de l'esque jambier
et là j'en suis à ma 3è j'ai poussé mon
corps à bout depuis très très jeune
et et donc je pense que là il me dit
clairement stop si aujourd'hui Nathalie
arrive à mieux doser ses
entraînements d'autres ont toujours du
mal à y renoncer à Nant cette jeune
femme s'est découverte récemment malade
de la pratique du
sport son abus est considéré par les
scientifiques comme une addiction au
même titre que l'alcool ou les drogues
les mécanismes psychiqu à l'œuvre
seraient les mêmes cependant pour la
plupart de ces sportifs assidu C cette
addiction est difficile à accepter mais
quand j'en ai pris conscience ouais ça
m'a ça m'a un peu embêté de reconnaître
en fait que bah j'arrivais
pas j'avais plus le contrôle en fait
ouais il y a toujours un truc de dire et
merde je croyais que j'allais gérer et
en fait je gère pas beaucoup je pense
comme une personne qui est dépendante je
pas à l'alcool ou même au tabac et c'est
clairement une addiction qui est qui est
valor en fait vaut mieux faire je sais
pas 10 à 15 heures de sport par semaine
plutôt que de passer 10 à 15 heures par
semaine à boire de l'alcool ou prendre
de la cocaïne ou il y a un côté où les
gens le valorisent les gens sont là à
dire mais c'est génial tu as trop de
chance d'avoir cette volonté
ouais mais après les gens voient pas
forcément que c'est pas qu'une volonté
en fait c'est aussi un besoin et et que
il y a tous ouais les mêmes choses en
fait la
souffrance la difficulté à contrôler ses
ses
comportements face à ces difficultés
elle a décidé de se faire accompagner en
allant chaque semaine au service
d'adidictologie du CHU de
Nantes le docteur pretagu chef du
service s'est spécialisé dans la prise
en charge de l'addiction au
sport
bonjour selon lui cette maladie doit
être prise plus au
sérieux le sport est Valis globalement
et donc on ne repère pas spécifiquement
cette problématique qui pourtant se
prend en charge de
façon assz enfin pas simple en tout cas
donne des résultats très tôt en tout cas
faire l'ut Truche ne sert à rien une
addiction peut en cacher d'autres il
faut donc savoir réagir vite c'est bien
souvent d'ailleurs à l'adolescence que
les les problématiques d'addiction se
mettent en place parfois plus plus tard
mais on peut passer d'une addiction à
une autre donc l'objet peut être
l'alimentation pour les troubles
alimentaires peut être la drogue pour
toxicomanie peut être le sport dans
d'autres cas et donc au fil de sa vie on
peut rester sur une même addiction
éventuellement la prendre en charge
c'est mieux où on peut passer d'un d'un
objet à un autre comme c'est le cas
souvent dans le sport certaines études
scientifiques montrerai une
surreprésentation des sportifs de haut
niveau dans les différentes catégories
d'addiction être addicte au sport serait
donc d'aut en plus néfaste sur le long
terme car il peut arriver de glisser
d'une addiction à une
autre Guillaume toucouet vous vous avez
eu une addiction ça veut dire quoi que
vous étiez en manque dire qu'il fallait
que vous vous exerciez tout le temps
c'était quoi cette addiction elle se
manifestait comment c'est ça alorsi
quand j'étais quand j'étais rameur je je
m'en apercevais pas parce que on est
toujours dans cette pratique sportive
tout le temps tout le temps donc là où
où j'en ai vraiment pris conscience
c'est justement quand j'ai arrêté
l'aviron où là ben j'avais plus du tout
la même dépense énergétique et mon corps
me réclamait quelque chose mais vous éti
pas
bien j'étais assez très vite agacé je
transpirais je tremblais j'avais des des
symptômes de manque tout simplement et
donc ben je partais courir je pais
courir je partais faire du vélo pour
aller chercher justement cette orine
pour me calmer ouais ça vous calmait
ouais et là j'ai trouvé ça mais la nuit
compris la nuit ah oui je me réveiller
en pleine nuit et je suis partis courir
à 2 3h du matin voilà donc j'en ai parlé
à mon médecin qui m'a dit mdium c'est
c'est une maladie que que touche
certains sportifs donc ah bon bigorexie
bon je connaissais pas j'avais jamais
entendu et donc effectivement quand
quand j'ai appris à à lire cette maladie
effectivement je me retrouvais beaucoup
dans dans ces symptômes là donc ben j'ai
réussi à m'en sortir en en réduisant un
petit peu le l'intensité de mes
entraînements parce que on en a tous
autour de nous des des joggers par
exemple is
ils se sentent pas bien ils se sentent
pas bien le matin s'ils vont pas courir
euh faire leur demi-heure leur heure de
course et on dit disons ils sont super
quand même ils court tous les jours en
fait ils sont addicts oui alors il y a
plusieurs phases hein il y a aussi je
pense que le premier le premier niveau
c'est vraiment le bien-être c'est vrai
que quand on se lève le matin qu'on va
courir après on a l'impression d'avoir
réussi sa journée déjà avant de l'avoir
commencé et après oui après a la partie
un peu plus adtive quand on en fait
vraiment à fond tous les jours et là
c'est un peu plus problématique en tout
cas faire attention si effectivement on
se sent mal donc vous vous aviez les
mêmes symptômes que quelqu'un en manque
donc de la transpiration des tremblement
il fallait que vous partiez pour vous
calmer ouais intéressant ça va mieux oui
très ça va très bien maintenant comme
c'est la règle dans cette émission on
interpelle un député vous avez voulu
poser une question sur la prévention de
la santé mentale dans le monde du sport
et c'est arwan balanan député MoDem du
finisterère qui vous répond lui-même a
été d'ailleurs un athlète de haut niveau
dans sa jeunesse alors monsieur le
député euh que proposez-vous en terme de
[Musique]
prévention moi je pense que c'est dans
le rôle déjà des éducateurs sportifs dès
le plus jeune âge de rappeler au à
l'enfant mais aussi aux parents et c'est
important que que le sport c'est pas non
plus euh que une histoire de performance
c'est une histoire de de recherche de
bien se sentir d'être bien d'un
complément d'une activité intellectuelle
que l'on a et et voilà et donc c'est
c'est c'est important que les
aujourd'hui que les éducateurs soient
formés à un minimum de psychologie
est-ce qu'ils le sent suffisamment je
suis pas complètement sûr moi j'ai eu la
chance d'avoir un entraîneur qui se
préoccupait de ça mais je sais que j'ai
des camarades qui qui qui pouvaient être
en souffrance parce que leur entraîneurs
sont s'occupaient de la performance
athlétique mais la performance
athlétique et ça c'est ce qu'avait
compris mon entraîneur elle ne elle ne
va nulle part si vous n'avez pas une une
si vous êtes pas bien dans votre
[Musique]
tête Guillaume toucouet ce que dit arwan
balanan c'est que il faudrait donc
former les éducateurs sportifs à en
parler aux enfants mais aussi aux
parents ça c'est intéressant que les
parents préviennent leurs enfants ou
soient plus attentifs au risque pour la
santé mentale d'une activité de haut
niveau c'est une bonne idée oui enfin je
trouve que c'est une très bonne idée
mais il faut toujours faut-il être formé
à ça savoir pourquoi l'enfant réagit
comme ça c'est c'est pas non plus
évident quand notamment quand on arrive
à l'adolescence il y a il y a plein de
sujets qui perturbent les enfants ou les
ados et du coup ben ouais c'est bien
d'être formé aussi et les éducateurs
sportifs pour moi c'est c'est primordial
de les de les de les sensibiliser
là-dessus mais bon j'ai bon espoir que
ce soit fait on commence vraiment à en
parler de plus en plus donc j'espère oui
ouis voilà il faut en parlerin merci
infiniment je sais pas si vous vous dire
bonne chance en tout cas on le pense
très fort merci beaucoup à Guillaume
toucoulet d'avoir été avec nous dans ce
numéro d'état de santé Merci à
[Musique]
VOUS LCP Assemblée Nationale en
partenariat avec MGEN vous a présenté
état de
santé